the gulf between vision and reality
rarely yawns as wide as at trade shows
at farnborough air travel is green
high-tech hassle-free
in the real world cues stretch
baggage piles up and pilots strike at
farnborough boris johnson is a top gun
in an raf typhoon in the real world his
angry party has just given the british
prime minister the boot
sculpted for speed and safety
engineered for a sustainable future but
if we're to glimpse how we might fly
tomorrow it is at farnborough
boom supersonic wants to bring back
supersonic air travel two decades after
concord was grounded
we deeply believe in a future where more
people can go more places more often
we believe that speed enables that
future
and therefore it's not good enough just
to make a little bit of progress on
efficiency we need to make a big leap
forward and completely remove
sustainability as a reason not to travel
and hybrid air vehicles is making the
air landers part airship part plane part
helicopter its low emissions won't need
a runway and would carry passengers or
freight the landscape developing here
isn't there with developments towards
implementation of sustainable aviation
fuels the ongoing efficiency
improvements that we get from jet
aircraft and a move to hydrogen which is
a part of our story here and our plan
here to bring hydrogen-powered aviation
into into the mix and we need all of it
we need all of it and we need more
miguel falcon is from spanish carrier
air nostrum his company is buying 10
airlanders this aircraft does not
require an airfield as such and it can
land on water and on land so that opens
up the possibility to enhance our
network and so those are the key aspects
of why we decided to go with this
aircraft and hopefully in 2036 it'll be
a reality
the uk government has just launched jet
zero requiring domestic aviation and
airports to reach net zero carbon
emissions by 2040 other governments are
moving too covid was an earthquake for
the aviation industry with air travel
all but shutting down the current star
shortages and disruptions show that
aftershocks are still reverberating and
may continue into 2023 according to air
bosses
add in the need to minimize how
polluting aviation is
and these are turbulent times for the
industry rory helens al jazeera the
farnborough air show